Tucked inside this silver paper is the world's most expensive chocolate bar,...
...priced at an indulgent 345 dollars for less than two ounces.
Jerry Toth is a cofounder of To'ak Chocolate.
His bars are made with a cacao called nacional, found in the rainforests of Ecuador.
The bean is so rare, it was thought to be extinct until just a few years ago.
It's known for its floral aroma and complex flavors.
Once harvested, the seeds are fermented in Spanish elmwood,...
...dried and only the best ones are hand-selected for the pricey confection.
The only other ingredient used in making the To'ak bars is pure cane sugar.
The exclusive treat gets the name Cognac Cask Matured...
...because it's aged for 18 months in a 50-year-old French oak cognac barrel.
Only 100 bars are made each year.
Jerry tells us they're almost all sold out.
Each one comes in a handcrafted Spanish elmwood box...
...with a bar number engraved on the back.
And because the extraordinary delicacy should never be touched with bare hands,...
...also inside: tasting tweezers made from Ecuadorian bamboo.